la première oeuvre que vous pouvez
découvrir restaurer chasseurs dans un
paysage de géraudel péquignot la
directrice du musée des balles
délicatement les oeuvres retire le
papier bulle comme du papier cadeau
les premiers tableaux principalement de
girodet ou des représentations du
peintre né à montargis font enfin leur
retour au musée du même nom ni un
travail extraordinaire fait part par les
restaurateurs sur des problématiques que
parfois très très complexe nettoyage de
la couche picturale une tension aussi
d'aider des oeuvres des toiles qui
avaient été parfois pour certaines
extrêmement détendus par rapport à
l'immersion et puis après vous avez tous
le toutou la dernière phase qui consiste
à ce qu'on appelle la réintégration ce à
dire au repiquage des des lacunes ses
oeuvres reviennent de loin au printemps
2016 les réserves où elle était stockée
se sont retrouvées inondées de l'eau
devenue le cauchemar du musée girodet à
montargis depuis qu'elle s'est engouffré
par cette grille dans les réserves où
étaient stockés près de trois mille
oeuvres qu'il faut remonter une à une
pour constater les dégâts
celle-ci est peut-être perdu ses deux
jours dans l'eau donc falloir faire un
premier état des lieux pour savoir ce
qu'il en est et quelles ont été les
conséquences de cette immersion les
premiers jours des restaurateurs
bénévoles ont donné les premiers soins
après des mois de séchage les
collections été confié à l'atelier de
restauration de versailles et à des
ateliers privés le coût estimé des
restaurations dépasse le million d'euros
il ya eu en effet l'aide de l'état qui
est intervenu
dans le cadre d'un accord cadre qui a
permis en effet de débloquer 800 mille
euros pour l'ensemble de à la fois des
phases de sauvetage mais aussi de
restauration au total près de 500
oeuvres prioritaires vont
progressivement retrouver leurs
nouvelles réserves
les autres ne figureront pas dans le
parcours de visite
certaines sont déjà entrés qui ne seront
que stabiliser c'est à dire que tout un
travail sur le support et sur lala sur
l'état de conservation de l'oeuvre est
réalisée mais nous n'allons pas jusqu'à
la phase finale qui est celle de la
réintégration
le musée est encore vide de ses 13
heures il ne devrait pas rouvrir au
public avant la fin de l'année demain
nous vous proposerons une visite en
avant première